ils disent tout ce qu'ils n'ont pas reçu
d'ordre de quitter batmout hier ils ont
dit les soldats qui ont pu parler à
Constantine
ils ont dit que la situation sur le
terrain n'avait pas vraiment changé dans
les derniers 24 heures ce qui veut dire
que les forces russes contrôlent une
partie de l'est de la ville de bakemout
il y a des combats de rue qui évidemment
sont très difficiles pour les deux côtés
et la ville est entourée sur les trois
côtés en forme de fer à cheval mais les
Ukrainiens ont encore accès par une
brèche d'environ 4 km de largeur dans
les lignes russes mais ils sont obligés
d'utiliser des chemins goudronnés non
goudronnés pardon ce qui devient de plus
en plus difficile à mesure que les
températures augmentent c'est presque
arrivé déjà au moment selon un soldat
que à qui on a parlé que seulement les
véhicules achevés les chars etc peuvent
chenilles peuvent passer pour les
véhicules à roues ça devient risqué je
ne sais pas si les Ukrain vont arriver à
améliorer la situation peut-être prendre
le contrôle d'une route goudronnée mais
ça c'est quelque chose qui est forcément
prise en considération quand les
Ukrainiens décident si ils peuvent ou
non continuer à garder la ville ils
disent tout de même que la boue pose des
problèmes peut-être plus importants
encore pour l'attaquant et c'est
peut-être aussi pour cela que il reste
déterminé à essayer de garder batmouth
mais maintenant ils disent librement
qu'il est possible qu'ils vont devoir
quitter batbout se retirer de cette
ville mais ils insistent qu'aucune
décision n'a été prise pour le moment je
rajouterais aussi que une grande partie
des soldats à qui on a parlé était
visiblement extrêmement fatigué et
stressé par leurs expériences